I think today people have started to
think journaling just means writing down
your feelings or writing down your
thoughts which is yeah this is no no I
mean I think it's good to write down
your feelings of course yeah so to bring
them forward to look up to up to you and
to look at them is that a good that's a
good exercise and so it's really when
you're in a situation
what are you going to do in that
situation and why and of course it
starts with your deeper needs whatever
they may be what do I want out of life
who do I want to be with what are the
directions okay and then it comes down
to the particulars and the particulars
can be
um aspirational I'm 73 years old I know
that at this particular part in life I
want to pass along the things that are
valuable for me it could be on how do
you fire a person how how do you treat
that person it could be what is your
relationship like and so those are the
principles
um it's not just it's not journaling
feelings and I so that found that very
very valuable